les manifestants juste derrière moi qui
enchaîne les prises de parole depuis 14h
sans médecins scientifiques présidents
d'associations parents d'enfants malades
ou encore simple soutien ils sont venus
aujourd'hui des quatre coins de la
france pour porter haut et fort leur
lutte contre les cancers pédiatriques
cette initiative de marie thibeault elle
est la fondatrice de l'association stop
au cancer de nos enfants est elle même
maman d'un enfant malade je vous propose
de l'écouter c'est c'est l'hécatombe
c'est un tsunami c'est sonne quand on
déclare le cancer de son enfant on nous
met face à la mort de notre enfant fait
et donc chaque jour on avance en
espérant que le nôtre fera pas partie
des 500 enfants qui décèdent chaque
année du cancer et puis après on se bat
on rentre dans le combat parce que nos
enfants il n'a jamais jamais jamais
jamais
jamais une seule seconde il n'arrête et
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir un petit
garçon qui va bien aujourd'hui qui est
rentré en phase de guérison donc les
cinq ans ont passé je sais par où il est
passé je sais qu'il est passé à ça dit
rester aussi je sais ici derrière moi
toutes les familles qui ont perdu leurs
enfants
et ça y'a rien normale dans tout ça est
une de ce combat là je vois pas comment
c'est pas possible pas en faire une
force en fait des cancers qui touchent
chaque année 2500 enfants et en tue
entre 400 et 500 et pour lesquels la
recherche n'est pas encore assez poussée
avec un manque d'essais cliniques des
causes de maladies inexpliquée par les
autorités sanitaires des traitements peu
adapté avec parfois de très lourdes
séquelles et en temps de campagne
présidentielle certains candidats ont
déjà pris parti
droits à congés en cas de règles
douloureuses ou pour les parents
d'enfants atteints par un cancer tva à
2,1 pour cent pour les produits
d'hygiène féminine la santé des femmes
les cancers pédiatriques et la santé
mentale seront les trois grandes causes
de mon quinquennat je refuse que des
enfants soient malades et meurent parce
qu'on ne les a pas protégés aujourd'hui
je vais à la rochelle dans un village où
il ya un nombre important de cancer
pédiatrique
nous ferons de la santé environnementale
une priorité
pour rappel une rallonge de 20 millions
d'euros a été voté en octobre dernier à
l'assemblée nationale pour la recherche
contre les cancers pédiatriques et
demain ce sera sandrine jaussaud débuté
modem de loire-atlantique qui organisera
un colloque à l'assemblée pour faire le
point sur ce budget à la veille de la
journée internationale des cancers de
l'enfant